"f" es una función lineal,
algunos de sus valores se muestran en la tabla a continuación,
en esta tablita de aquí.
¿Cuáles gráficas representan funciones
que crecen a la misma razón que "f"?
Así que primero,
encontremos la razón de cambio de "f"
si pasa de que "x" valga 0
a "x" valga 4,
entonces tengo un cambio neto
de 4 unidades
y eso se refleja en un cambio de...
de -1 pasa 6
así que en un cambio de 7... 7 unidades positivas
en el valor de "f".
Por lo tanto la razón de cambio de "f" es de siete cuartos,
y quiero
encontrar ¿cuál de estas rectas tiene una pendiente también de 7 cuartos?
O lo que es lo mismo,
¿Cuál de estas rectas es paralela a la recta que representa "f"?
y bueno,
el modo más fácil de hacer eso es graficar a "f".
Voy a tomar cualesquiera
pareja de puntos
que sean parte de los valores que toma "f".
Podría tomar cualesquiera dos porque es una función lineal.
Cuando "x" vale 0
"f" vale -1
y cuando "x" vale 4...
cuando "x" vale 4,
"f" de "x" vale 6,
"f" de 4 es 6,
así que estaría aquí.
De modo que la gráfica de "f"
se ve algo así.
Es una recta que se ve así.
Entonces,
¿cuál de estas rectas es paralela a esta recta?
pues de hecho puedo decir incluso más,
puedo decir que "a"
es una recta que crece más rápido que "f"...
crece más rápido que "f",
tiene más inclinación,
"b" es una función decreciente,
así que ni la tengo que considerar
"c" crece más lento que "f"
está de aquí es "f"
porque la recta tiene menos inclinación
y parece que "d" es la opción correcta
parece que estas dos rectas son paralelas.
Vamos a verificarlo
la razón de cambio...
la razón de cambio de "f",
es cuánto cambia el valor de la función
dado un cambio en el valor de "x".
así que bien,
si cambio "x" por 4 unidades...
si "x" cambia en 4 unidades,
entonces "f" cambia en 7 unidades
de modo que la pendiente de "f" es de siete cuartos.
Eso significa,
que si yo me paro en este punto de la gráfica de "d"
y yo me muevo 4 unidades positivas,
o sea me muevo la derecha 4 unidades,
entonces para que "d"
crezca a la misma razón que "f"
para regresar a la gráfica a partir de este punto,
tendría que alzarme siete unidades,
veamos
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
en efecto,
regreso a la gráfica, por lo tanto,
"d" tiene la misma pendiente que "f"
"d" es la opción correcta.